we had the greatest glow up of all time
i'm as surprised as you are
some of the greatest women of all time
luxury
yellow corn and an appearance from our
bachelorette which one which one am i
talking about i don't know
she got her fairy tale ending and that's
what i wanted what episode is this we
had two weeks off i don't know
nine whatever this is your the bachelor
season one episode
recap it's nick by all season grab your
glasses
it's time for roses and rose
hi everybody it's me lauren zema
oh it's been two weeks and things have
been heating up haven't they yes
so happy to be back and by heating up i
mean
in so many ways uh the bachelor world
news is heating up you know we got
claire
we got tasha what's going on we're gonna
talk a little bit about that
and then just i also i'm quite literally
heating up because
i want to let you guys in on a little
behind the scenes
it is 80 degrees in this apartment
yes we're having a heat wave in los
angeles as of late
and i had not been in this apartment
much lately
i pretty much only film here so you know
i didn't turn my ac
on and now it appears to be broken so
we're filming
it's warm it's warm and you know i tend
to sweat i do
chris harrison doesn't sweat it's
strange it's
it's unnerving before we get to all that
drama let's start with
nick and of course we need to get to our
rose because it's actually
part of what's keeping me cool today
i've got a glass of ice
and a rose that's real nice um this is
called
roditis it is dry rose wine but called
rodatus because it's from greece
i don't know if i've ever discussed this
with you guys but
i grew up thinking i was greek
um and then i uh i took an ancestry dna
thing
uh through a collaboration for work
actually and found out
i'm not yeah not at all greek not one
drop so
i still love my greek wines i still love
my greek food
i grew up going to greek church
sometimes it was weird it was a lot to
process
it's a story for another time um but
you know it was a thing to realize
tula eat something people have seen
weird stuff on those ancestry dna things
i mean i've known
i knew somebody who found out their dad
wasn't their dad so
i'm gonna count my blessings
let's get to it
so good so greek speaking of origin
stories
transition much i just nailed that
nick viall's origin story on his season
of the bachelor
began long before he ever hit
that wet driveway in the suit it began
a couple other times he hit that wet
driveway he was on of course andy
dorfman's season of the bachelorette
where he was dumped in caitlyn bristow's
season of the bachelorette where he was
dumped and then he was on bachelor in
paradise
where he dumped someone for a change
someone's telling me to say goodbye
and because on next season we always
have to relive all that
we also relive all that look
yes don't drink for every time nick
looked real different on past seasons of
the
shows
i'm bringing it up because i want to
raise my glass up to the nick viall
glow up do you think nick's bachelor
glow up
was the greatest of all time the
greatest glow up of all time the goat
i think it was i don't know anyone who
did it better um
nick showed up on paradise looking
fab he'd grown that hair out a little
bit he'd grown those muscles a lot a bit
and he'd grown that beard out and
everybody let's settle in
let's grab our glasses because i want to
talk about
scruff i've discussed it on the show
with you guys before but i had a
realization today
you know i always thought of it as a
personal affinity you know do you like a
little scruff on a man or not
i've now realized i think every guy
looks better with scruff do you agree
bold statements big statements things
are heating up let me know in the
comments below
maybe if it's like patchy then it's not
going to improve someone's appearance
but
i really was racking my brain i can't
think of anyone whether i know them or
they're famous or whatever
who doesn't look better with a little
well five o'clock shadow
but you know it shapes the jawline
chrysant do you agree christian agrees
jc yes cheers to that
[Music]
i just i just don't like you okay no
that's fair i sometimes i don't like me
no no now
whether nick was ultimately one of the
best
bachelors of all time but his season was
great
and in large part because the women were
phenomenal don't drink for every
favorite face we got
at an egg vial season we had rachel
jasmine alexis the dolphin shark come on
down
sweet southern raven several danielle's
christina taylor vanessa
and of course corinne that was a lot
i'm probably forgetting someone if i
didn't
oh she's going for it then corrine got
topless okay
it's the first group date okay and on
the first group date
they put these women in wedding dresses
in a variety of wedding scenarios
for nick viall who's been dumped twice
when trying to propose and don't drink
for
every one of the other women who looked
so uncomfortable
everyone felt really uncomfortable
seeing nick with corinne we're gonna
jenna jackson
[Applause]
like how would you react in that
situation
some of the women got mad i feel i would
just kind of laugh and raise my glass
and say you do you girl
you know that was a problem with corinne
and the other ladies
they worried way too much about herself
and not enough about themselves
there definitely was another spark in
that pool him holding
my bare bosoms you know
i'm gonna call corrin one of the
greatest contestants of all time
do you agree let me know in the comments
below she's one of the greatest
contestants of all time
the coat the good coat
[Music]
acronyms i tell you don't drink for
every iconic moment
corinne brought us the bouncy house
having fun her revealing that she had a
nanny at age 24.
raquel is my nan the number of times she
mentioned cheesy pasta
which is just macaroni and cheese right
and i can't make cheese pasta like her
she basically reinvented mac and cheese
it makes her happy and i'm not going to
stop a woman's happiness
and of course when she missed a rose
ceremony
where's corinne to take a nap
my eyes weren't even open when i was
saying that in honor of corinne
i'm not sure if anyone had ever done
that before uh bachelor historians
let me know in the comments below if i'm
forgetting but had anyone ever
been absent from a rose ceremony because
they were asleep
i don't think so i really really have
guys
i love it so corinne was certainly a
character but the question at the time
was
was she a villain what did you guys
think i'll say this
karim didn't really say anything mean
about the other women
she was just kind of doing her thing you
know and then they committed the faux
pas
of going and talking to nick about it
don't drink every time one of the women
told nick
karen is it right for you how serious is
she taking this and
i know how serious is for you karen is
24
and has a nanny starting to kind of
question
where you're at based on the attention
that has been given to korea and when
corinne found out this was happening
she coined some of the best catchphrases
we have ever seen she was luxury
yellow corn gotta peel the layers back
and then middle is this luxury yellow
corn yes corinne compared herself to
corn and she would go on to call herself
corn and it's juicy buttery and
the thing is it was an analogy that made
sense
you want to get to that corn oh but then
there was
taylor taylor came for corinne with the
phrase of her own
emotional intelligence okay emotional
and there's emotional intelligence where
that kind of speaks to like
self-awareness not really of her own i
mean certainly she didn't
coin that but she came with it she
thinks i'm stupid and i'm not
emotionally intelligent
and i'm not mature enough to be in a
relationship with nick
and they ended up on a two-on-one and
corrine said she was bullied
she emotionally attacked me and taylor
said she was not the villain
i am certainly not the villain in this
and now we
zoom catch up with taylor the therapist
who calls the whole thing a quote
mind kind of a
a bit of a mind
[Music]
[Music]
sad were you on i was on karen's
i i really was even now you guys taylor
and corinne
have not made any amends and taylor
thinks that karin owes her an apology
but
i really do think karen was just doing
her thing and you know taylor got lost
in the corn
she got lost in that field of corn that
luxury yellow corn
corn grows high i think she's lost and
then she can see her way out
don't focus on herself focus on yourself
you know build yourself up don't worry
about tearing others down
it's going to be better in the long run
promise and now rachel
yes rachel lindsay was a
front-runner on nick by all season of
the bachelor and
i think rachel and nick really did have
a connection
obviously it ultimately wasn't that love
forever connection but i think they both
really respected each other's intellect
and were sort of fascinated by each
other and on this episode we revisited
when nick went to rachel's hometown
and spoke with her family about what it
would be like for them to date as an
interracial couple
i feel like you've seen more racism come
out and so he does need to be aware
it's not something that you can just
hide and ignore and you can live in your
own bubble
and now we're back on the zooms joined
by two alumni to discuss rachel's impact
on the franchise overall
natasha from peter webber's recent
season of the bachelor
and then wait is that
is that is that
tasha adams i'm sorry i was really
building up the anticipation but it was
worth building up because
we are talking with tasha adams
she was so true and authentic to herself
i don't know what's
happening here tasha adams is you know
what i didn't think
everybody take a drink because we gotta
process this tasha adams
is on this zoom with natasha and chris
harrison
to talk about rachel lindsay's impact on
the franchise it's a very important
conversation about how rachel
gave tasha and natasha someone who
looked like them as an example on the
show
and helped inspire them to go on the
show period
but also tasha's like our bachelorette
so my mind is going crazy right now
was she the bachelorette when they
filmed this was she not
but did they know she would be the
bachelorette when they filmed this did
they know nothing at all
there was no mention of tasha being
the bachelorette but you know there she
is
it seems like nobody knew tasha from
colton underwood season
thank you for having us and i want to
point out
a sentence tasha said because if she
didn't know she was the bachelorette
then
if nobody knew she was going to be the
bachelorette then this sentence
is just really beautiful she said of
rachel
she got her fairy tale ending and gave
us
hope she got her fairy tale ending um
and that's what i wanted so she gave us
hope
tasha tasha we have hope for you
we love you we stand you we cannot wait
to watch you cheers to tasha
but this is about nick and you know
tasha wasn't even on his season but
raven was
pink yes raven
a beloved gal in the franchise was also
on nick viall's season she was the
runner up
it's beyonce from here on out yes
nick broke up with raven my heart's
somewhere else and
i called the ladies out for a faux pas
earlier and now i gotta call out nick
he told raven that his heart was torn it
just like breaks
and i'm just like torn up inside letting
you go and let me lay out another
extreme
just like it's always great to have
scruff i don't think it's ever okay
to talk about how in pain you are when
you're dumping someone
i'm just like torn up inside especially
on national television what do you think
let me know in the comments below i
understand
that nick probably really did feel bad
and that he knew
raven was an amazing woman and respected
her but when you say that
you just make it about you you know and
let the focus be on the other person
because they're the one who's in the
vulnerable position
okay by the way i um
actually have these glasses because i
ate at a restaurant in greece
and the glasses were there and i thought
oh my gosh these like local grecian
glasses
these are so amazing i have to have them
and i was all ready to like buy them in
greece and pack them up and
like carry them back to the us and i
asked the restaurant where did you get
these amazing
locally crafted artisanal handmade
glasses
and they said amazon
but i still ordered them you know and
i'm here because
you know sometimes what matters is the
origin story that's in our heads
what do you believe for yourself
manifest it make it happen you know here
i
am here i am oh thank you thank you
very very much i'm drinking wine so
life's not too bad
oh goodness by the way
just to have a little fun don't drink
for every lantern
at this proposal beautiful thank you
you look
yes i don't remember where they were it
was clearly quite cold
snow on the ground and maybe because it
was so cold
they were they were for heat they were
functional
they weren't
so raven is leaving and nick
is praying question mark
yeah nick's doing this i don't know why
i'm not sure what he's doing
maybe it's so cold that he's almost
stopping up the snot from rolling down
his face
you know when it's like cold and you
start snotting fingers were right under
the nostrils
this is not a very coveted friendly
position i will say that
i don't know but i do want to open the
door and discuss
nick viall's tears
yes you guys let's look at the evidence
don't drink every time nick cried this
season
a wasted tears you know
wasted broken hearts and you've been so
selfless
[Music]
and now the big moment after three
seasons
is the fourth time the charm it wasn't
but nick viall did
propose elsa hi chris
yes nick proposed to vanessa and you
know i got confused for a minute because
i was like are we in the same place did
we change locations
because when raven was there were there
deer yeah vanessa pulls up and these
deer
or maybe they're the reindeer is there a
difference between deer and reindeer
are they elk there's animals a foot
with their a hoof a hoove with their
hooves
uh greatest deer of all time good don't
like gal gadot oh wonderful oh i wish
that movie would come out
oh i want movies to come out again i
really wanted to see the new bond movie
and i want to see the new top gun i want
to see
tenet from christopher nolan i really
wanted wonder woman to come out what
movie were you guys most disappointed
about
getting postponed let me know in the
comments below
i love the movies chris and i do love
going to the movies together and just
watching movies at home
the other day i facetimed him and he was
watching
i will tell you he was watching the
devil wears prada
alone that's not an unusual thing for
him
he loves stanley tucci can we adjust the
attitude i'm sorry
yes as vanessa pulls up and gets
surrounded by
dasher and dancer and prancer and
blitzen and common and cupid and
donner and who's that last one
i don't know but i'm ready for christmas
we need some joy
i'm ready for movies weddings the
bachelorette and christmas
so as vanessa is pulling up nick is
preparing
to propose and you know he's talking
about how much he loves vanessa
i've been falling in love with vanessa
for a very long time the words he's
using
are beautiful but the tone
in which she's saying them is
questionable i've been falling in love
with vanessa for a very long time and
it's been
[Music]
he's saying all these happy things about
how in love with vanessa he is
but he sounded so sad
i'm going to ask vanessa to marry me all
right vanessa's coming in and it is the
same place yes i'm recognizing the
lanterns
but this time don't drink for all the
dear el corn things
we got horns on the chandeliers we got
horns around the rows
i think the rose was on table of horns
whatever
were those real if they were i'm not
sure i support that
okay so nick is doing and he's proposing
to vanessa and he says
if i leave here alone i'll be devastated
if i leave here alone i'll be devastated
and make you already
sound devastated and he says it'll be a
waste of tears it would have been
a lot for nothing i wasted tears well
that is true
and then vanessa comes in and nick is
crying
look you know i just it was a very sweet
reaction
when vanessa walked through the door and
honestly even though
nick and vanessa didn't work out this
whole proposal was really beautiful
wasn't it i mean
let's pretend we're at the movies and
just listen to some of what they said
[Music]
i will never forget the first one
but i'll never forget the first moment i
started falling in love with you
every moment since then i've been
falling
more and more with you
[Music]
i do love you i'm in love with you
[Music]
philly mary
[Applause]
okay i think we got it so we catch up
with vanessa and nick
and you know what they're on good terms
she's happily engaged
i'm in in a very happy healthy
relationship
he's happily single i am proudly single
we raise the glass to the happy mass
slant rhyme so nick is still single
so yeah you know i guess i have to ask
nick is the bachelor round two
no it's not a good idea no it's not
second i said it i knew it was put those
words back in the mouth
as a literary device we call that word
vomit
definitely not no
absolutely negative don't do it
okay all right everybody this has been
nick by all season of the bachelor and
we only have
one episode left of the greatest seasons
of all time
sho gazot that is going to be
juan pablo season we will be here next
week
reviewing it of course on roses and rose
juan pablo the most hated bachelor in
the history of our franchise
and you know they teased to it at the
end of this episode
so you know who's in that footage of
course claire
crowley yeah they're like it's our
bachelorette
claire crawley it introduced us to a
woman who stole
everyone's heart with her passion so i'm
just thinking
okay is this like are we in inception
how did you get here are we in the
matrix
what movie are we in because we had
botasia
our bachelorette and now claire our
bachelorette
in the same greatest of all time episode
[Music]
i love you guys so much thank you for
watching roses and rose
as always if you would like a personal
message from me for you or someone you
love i am on the app
cameo i am also on instagram tick tock
and twitter you can find me and follow
me and
i would adore it if you did thank you
thank you thank you
and now you know like corinne i'm gonna
take a nap
okay so
bye i'm not gonna stop a woman's
happiness
why are you guys laughing because i ate
the whole pack by myself earlier
i just pulled this bag out of the trash
because
i ate it alone by myself earlier at the
whole bag before we started filming
oh my god it expired in december 2019